[Musique]
le 11 juin 1981 une date que personne ne
peut oublier à l'ischio gauche
apple nous avons été pris d'assaut par
500 agents de la police provinciale et
des gardes-pêche les forces de l'ordre
arrivent simultanément par la route la
rivière et les airs j'ai regardé dans
les airs il y avait un hélicoptère juste
au dessus nos têtes je me suis dit waouh
pourquoi volts ici bas puis j'en ai vu
d'autres et des bateaux qui arrivent
partout et où jacob corinne améliorée
des autos de police à chaque maison ou
presque
à partir de pointe-à-la-croix jusque de
l'autre côté du stick gauche deux jours
plus tôt le gouvernement de rené
lévesque avait lancé un ultimatum aux
pêcheurs de listuguj pour protéger les
stocks de saumon en déclin les micmacs
en 36 heures pour retirer leurs filets
mais certains défis québec la pêche de
subsistance est un droit ancestral
clame-t-il
les agents saisissent des saumons
détruisent les filets fouillent les
maisons et arrêtent brutalement 12
personnes et reliant tous passé
tellement vite
plusieurs personnes dont moi ont été
blessés j'étais entre autres battu
en d'autres mots il n'en traitait comme
des chiens puis dreadlocks pierre lepage
est dépêchée à listuguj par la
commission des droits de la personne
quelques heures après l'opération
policière véritablement une communauté
en commotion les gens pleuraient
ça touche r d tous les gens de la
communauté des gens qui n'avaient rien à
voir avec ces histoires de pêche les
femmes des enfants des vieillards et
cetera
alors tout le monde était coupable par
association c'était ça la réalité alors
c'était véritablement démesurée
malgré le choc listuguj tient tête à
québec les pêcheurs remettent des filets
à l'eau mais le 20 juin les forces de
l'ordre sont de retour et cette fois les
micmacs sont préparés ils bloquent tous
les accès à leur territoire
aidé par d'autres membres des premières
nations arrivées sans renfort la police
gless certains pêcheurs avec des balles
de plastique et lance des gaz
lacrymogènes mais elles plient bagage
sans avoir pu mettre les peas alice tout
gauche cette période en 1981 avec un
moment marquant pour la résistance
micmacs et pour les revendications de
nos droits envers les gouvernements et
les industries un an après la crise
liszt ou gaucher québec s'entendent sur
un quota de pêche et sur la protection
de la ressource
nous avons réussi à signer une entente
sur des bases solides mais le côté à
louis à la communauté mais jma diminue
au fil des ans
si bien qu'en 1993 listuguj défie à
nouveau la province et adopte sa propre
loi sur la pêche au saumon pour prouver
au gouvernement du québec que nous
pouvions gérer nos activités de pêche
sur notre propre rivière avec nos
propres agents et nous l'avons fait
quarante ans après les descentes
policières
c'est sans craint que les pêcheurs big
man entament leur saison listuguj assure
maintenant sa propre gouvernance dans
les eaux de la rivière restigouche vont
pouvoir exercer mon droit de pêche
chaque année nous allons mes chers amis
ne dit que c'est un honneur
ce sont désormais des gardes-pêche
mi'gmaq y applique la loi listuguj
encadre les périodes et les zones de
pêche mais n'impose aucun quota ni
restriction sur la longueur des prises
les autorités mises bas affirme
documenter les captures mais refuse de
révéler combien seulement son péché de
ce très durable au niveau de l'effort de
pêche qui est la scientifique carolanne
gillies travail avec les micmacs de
listuguj depuis sept ans elles assurent
que leur pêche de subsistance est mené
de façon responsable et qu'elle est
beaucoup moins dommageable que
l'exploitation commerciale fait par les
blancs dans la baie des chaleurs
jusque dans les années 80 ces cinq maris
sur 14 qui sont pêchés donc amplement de
marée pour la montaison de saumon
listuguj compte également sur sa propre
équipe scientifique pour assurer le
suivi des stocks de saumon nous pesons
les poissons les mesures ont enlevé les
écailles et en analysant touch peut
savoir leur âge premier temps ils ont
été dans la rivière où la séance ils
sont des mâles ou des femelles saison
frais liés ou non les événements de 1981
ont profondément marqué communauté liste
gauche mais plusieurs croient qu'ils ont
aussi contribué à son émancipation
au delà de la pêche au saumon nous
pouvons être fiers que notre communauté
a pris sa place à ce moment là et se
soient battus pour ses convictions sa
juste part pour avoir un moyen de
subsistance et sortir de l'aide sociale
un souvenir douloureux qui aura tout de
même pavé la voie à la reconnaissance
des droits ancestraux des premières
nations